Researcher Westrin selected 150 glass cups
filled with strawberry jelly for experimentation.
The first 50 cups were placed into the Clockworks
on the setting "Rough."
The output produced was a pile of glass shards
and strawberry jelly.
The second 50 cups were placed on the setting
"1:1."
The output produced was 50 cups made from
hardened strawberry jelly, filled with molten
glass.
The final 50 cups were placed on the setting
"Very fine."
The output was a glass item, resembling an
exact replica of a human skull, filled with
strawberry jelly.
Note: When the glass skull was created, it
managed to move its "jaw" and vocalized the
word "squish" before becoming inert again.
- Researcher Westrin